die gehen
[Musik]
brumby also ich finde ich der stadt
manche fans gefiel aber was ich glaube
ich nicht normal ich finde es normal
ich finde die sind nicht normal wie
labil das gefüge klappen normal wie man
sagte mir sehr viel ab aber das kann ich
dir der mache
gott sei dank dass nicht jeder stellt
davor wollen jedes wochenende aber wenig
denn wer in dieser geschichte geht es um
eine frau die freiheit und abenteuer
suchte und fand
[Musik]
dafür sind dem koffer sie lebt seit 25
jahren fernab der zivilisation im norden
von australien im so genannten art beck
ja stets wenig tief da das ist nur
einfach war hatten sie sich lieber gott
sagen was dafür kommen endlich geblieben
zusammen mit freiwilligen helfern hat
barbara walker über eine autostunde
entfernt von der nächsten stadt ein
kleines camp aufgebaut
rohes retreat in der regenzeit ist es
von der außenwelt abgeschnitten und
walker lebt hier als einsiedlerin jetzt
in der trockenzeit sind die straßen
passierbar besuch hat sie trotzdem kaum
in mehreren gehegen pepsi kleine
kängurus auf deren mütter von autos
totgefahren wurden taxen während sie
täglich stunden für jedes kleine leben
kämpft sehen viele australier kängurus
primär aus auf fressende plage und ihr
engagement als zeitverschwendung passion
wieder solide schafft wohne ich mache
das ich sich eis oder hauptprojekt
friedrich will die betreuung und uns
zweite ist umweltschutz
der riesige lotteriefonds unterstützt
ihr engagement finanziell und volontäre
helfen ihr das camp laufen zu
modernisieren
das thema ist noch nicht ganz fertig das
hörbuch noch linie arbeit aber
irgendwann fertig das ist das erste
sieht 220 jahre und ich richtig party
zimmermann und noch mit falsch damit
treffen statt den mann danach zur machen
oder ruf mache also das ist luxus
versionen hardebusch dass ich wirklich
an luxus version
um zu verstehen wieso die gelernte
lithograph in und passionierte
fotografen hier gelandet ist müssen wir
25 jahre zurück blenden
damals war die 40 und wollte australien
fotografischer kunden
unterwegs lernt die roboter können einen
cowboy der im outback lebte
sie verliebten sich und heirateten
neu war 64 also 24 jahre älter aussieht
2006 starb an krebs
sie ist geblieben und lebt seither von
einer witwenrente gestorben ich habe ich
mich gewöhnt aber was man anfangen sich
zu sich selber reden sagt ich spreche
das kommt automatisch und gute dazu der
dir aber was ich muss machen
ich muss da sein oder einmal im tag
werdet und trinke ich trinke ich einfach
nur was ist mit koffern voller magie und
dänische sei es aber wenn ich am
arabicas thema ein normales menü und
darum stellen caravan bildung muss ich
aber der fernsehen schaut da will ich
muss man schlicht muss man schließlich
stimme gehöre
[Musik]
ich das gefühl dass ich so schick soll
eben das gewisse man sich einfach
irgendwann in verbindung mit dem mit
ganze starke verbindung bereits nun zwar
hat er die falsche zahlen kopf
das ist ein guter mann ist für mich da
gewisse schönheit oder aber man muss
einfach sehen wie eine mal und nicht wie
eine frau
oder weil sie sich schon eine
gemeindliche
[Musik]
auch das australische fernsehen war
fasziniert von reuters herbem charme und
berichtete immer wieder über ihn
und als er plötzlich nicht mehr alleine
durchs leben ried wurde die geschichte
freilich noch interessanter
aber ein bisschen raus du woher kommt
sie aus der schweiz
sie ist die erste frau die ich je
gesehen habe
sie schiebt eine schubkarre voller
steine problemlos acht kilometer weit
und sie durchschwimmt jeden fluss wenn
es sein muss sogar mit der schubkarre
aus wie ein fernseher ein radio habe ich
verschenkt kein radio kein fernsehen
nein das brauche ich nicht die berichten
doch nur über mord krieg und
vergewaltigungen und über die verdammten
politiker mit ihrer macht und ihrem geld
da höre ich doch lieber den verdammten
vögeln zu
[Musik]
konfirmiert die der mann schwingt
wienerisch mit seinen charakter mal wo
smartphones im labor mit der natur
russland
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich nicht am anfang sehr
verbunden mit der natur und tierwelt und
der beziehung bin kann ich sehr ähnlich
also so wie ein geprügelter ja genau
[Musik]
sie lebt so gut wie möglich auch selbst
versorgen
zum einen weil es billiger ist zum
anderen weil sie befürchtet lebensmittel
die nicht streng biologisch angebaut
werden könnten sie krank machen
man möchte sie denn mal gestand werden
ja wer wo das nicht werde ich meine das
ist falsch
im labor bis positiv mache und nutzen
sorry ich bin etwas spät dran
ich habe die zeit komplett vergessen wir
filmen gerade wie ich erdbeeren pflanzen
schön sie kennenzulernen
die lokale tourismus industrie hat die
schweizer einsiedlerin im outback aus
attraktion entdeckt er glaubt nicht wie
schwer ein toter ist es ist nicht so wie
in den krimis wo man einen umbringt und
die leiche einfach über die schulter
wirft so einfach ist es nicht
das ist eher ein fall für die schubkarre
also haben wir euch schubkarre geholt
die da drüben da haben wir rein gelegt
aber seine beine waren schon steif da
habe ich gesagt ich hoffe einfach dass
ich ihm nicht noch die beine brechen uns
in der trockenzeit kommen oft mehrmals
wöchentlich touristengruppen vorbei
locker nimmt sie dann mit der france
letzte reise hier für einmal nicht auf
einem pferd sondern in einer schubkarre
antreibt gestoßen von seiner frau und
zwei von ihr angeforderten helferinnen
[Musik]
plötzlich tauchte ein helikopter auf das
sagte ich zu den beiden frauen bleibt
stehen
die eine fragte können sie uns sehen
ich sagte ja da meinte die andere die
denken sicher dass wir jemanden umgelegt
haben und die beweise loswerden wollen
[Musik]
einerseits bringen diese tour in einen
kleinen finanziellen zustupf für äußere
andererseits will sie mit diesen
führungen die am grab ihres mannes
senden sein andenken lebendig halten
ich hätte das nie könne
ich hätte das nie schöne verlag oder
zweiter sagte thiel
ich kenne ihn ja das wäre ich am anderen
ort wo fühlen und ich kann mich jetzt
wieder wie die schweiz zurück und co ich
würde dir vermisse hier lebt sie in
ihrem eigenen kleinen reich mitten in
der natur allerdings als eremitin
widerwillen ganz allein sein das wollte
sie nie das wollte das schicksal das
wurde ja im ferienhof sich läufer sohnes
labor cent billiger also fällt in eine
pizzabotin weniger hat man in japan wo
man wohnt den revisoren fehlt das geld
als auto und ich will zurück
aber so ist ein neuer partner trägt der
kreis sieht sie also aus aller welt nur
als arbeiter arbeiter starkem regen
schwer ist auch klopp aber die ihre
herzlichkeit platz mit 24 bit trainiert
soll ja wort liebe wegen wie anders
trotz einfach liebe zu dir herr war
schon der partner herrsche kein problem
kein problem
ja da hätte ich mich nicht handhaben
ich bin ja kein haut sie litern pro
manta mit einer fachperson du zum
beispiel gehen wird
aber das war schon eine gute seite der
oder
es fasziniert mich ein bisschen aber ich
war denn das mit dem fotografischen
aargau aus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ihr neuestes projekt in einem gehege
pflanzte bäume in deren schatten sich
antilopen känguru sparen sollen
denn das amt die loben känguru ist vom
aussterben bedroht
eine andere frage ist freilich wie es
mit wall street weiter geht wenn sie
einmal nicht mehr da ist und das
betreuen
ja aber die person geht es nicht einfach
um die ecke nummer befinden wo will ich
dass sie die sache sieht die machen
tschuldigung am wasser nicht was hinter
die türen nicht so super befinden oder
und in der ag zieht das ist was ich da
tue sie zu eis das ist mir ganz klar
[Musik]
heller bild es war immer klar dass ihr
mann nicht in einem spital in einer
stadt sterben wollte sondern zu hause in
australiens unendlicher weite betreut
von seiner frau im bett
die letzten zwei tagen immer bewusst
sexy und einfach vorzieht dem mx messe
flüssiges morphium gehe das nur die
schmerzen spürte dass sich den märkten
sogar zusammen die beiden finger finger
weiter blaue weite blick sieht
eigentlich wie maschine so langsam sich
gut abschalten
[Musik]
der sonntagmorgen gehört ganz ihrem mann
und der grabpflege
irgendwann will auch sie hier ihre
letzte ruhe finden
unklar ist allerdings noch ob jemand
bereit sein wird ihre schubkarre hier
her zu schieben
die möglichkeit hat dass die jüngere
frau ins grab gruppe hand und in sauber
beerdigt hat sich der völlig der jüngere
mann hätte gehört zurzeit sieht was ich
nun noch anregung ist groß
und dann vielleicht mit der flasche
widerwillig mit bäumen die kommando- und
zeitlich wie es fast limacher bist
einfach training noch eine spitze gegen
apple wird eine burg nicht finden und
kredite zur deckung brachte die knochen
seine lieblingsplätze hier her und er
wünschte sich dereinst auch hierzu
liegen
diesen wunsch hat ihm seine frau erfüllt
[Applaus]
bevor die räuber mit acht okay wenn man
tot ist ist einfach dort ist einfach
nicht mehr
soll ich mir das vorgestellt moderator
bin ich sind einfach ganz komische
ungewöhnliche sachen passiert also nicht
dass ich mir wie drogen vollem
bewusstsein und das hat mir danach riss
danke und das ist das was ich suche ja
da bin ich ganz sicher
da bin ich ganz sicher egal stirbt nie
[Musik]
begeistert dass ich die energie und vor
allem vor allem aber nicht zu der natur
lebt kann er das völlig besser empfangen
als oper wo hohe innere innere rettung
war glaubt weissenhofer größe und was
sie kosten
[Musik]
jede stirbt mal das ist einfach es war
einfach und das gehört das gehört in
sickels inne
aber ich glaube daran dass es anders
geht noch 100 prozentig glaube ich daran
[Musik]